[Music]
if you're building an app there's a good
chance that at some point you'll want to
convert your users into paying customers
the most popular api for doing just that
is stripe
it's the payment solution behind a huge
number of successful startups and
companies
like twitch squarespace and shopify just
to name a few
stripe has multiple javascript libraries
that you can implement in the front end
to easily collect credit card
information from your customers
in today's video you'll learn how to use
both stripe checkout and stripe elements
in an angular application
if you're new here like and subscribe
and you can grab the full source code on
fireship io
now the first thing i want to point out
is that this video is only covering the
front end implementation
that involves securely collecting credit
card information from the user and then
validating it with stripe but it does
not involve creating the actual charge
that will collect money from the user
for that you need a back-end
implementation and if you're using
firebase that means firebase cloud
functions luckily i just released my
full-length stripe payments master
course and it will show you how to
implement and test everything on the
back end as well as integrate it with
firebase
the course will show you how to build a
full stack payment solution similar to
the one i have on fireship io that
handle single charges subscriptions
coupons and more but enough of that
shameless plug let's get into our
angular application and start writing
some code
we're going to start with stripe
checkout which is very easy to implement
and does almost all the front-end work
for you when the user clicks on this buy
button
it will trigger this pop-up modal which
will then collect their credit card
information
and do all the validation directly in
that modal this is great as a drop-in
solution
but it doesn't give you a lot of
flexibility to customize the styling or
the entire checkout experience
now at this point i want to make it
clear that i'm using firebase in this
project
it's not at all required to work with
stripe and angular but i want to show
you what a real charge looks like
so in order to do that i've implemented
user authentication in this app as well
as firebase callable functions
as you can see i have those dependencies
in my app module via the angularfire
library
one other thing you'll probably want to
do is install the types for either
stripe checkout or stripe.js
just so you have autocomplete in your
ide as you're writing your code
from there we'll go into angular to the
index.html file
and then add the script for stripe
checkout stripe recommends including
this as a script tag in the html as
opposed to including it in your
javascript bundle
now i've created a component called
checkout and the first important thing
i'll do
is declare a namespace for stripe
checkout in the top of this file
and you can strong type it if you
installed the typings that i showed you
earlier then i'm adding my auth service
and angularfire functions to the
constructor
that's not required for stripe checkout
and you can replace that with nothing or
with your own logic
now there's a good chance you have more
than one product so we'll add input
properties here to pass in an amount
and also a description for the product
being sold then we'll declare a handler
which is the actual modal window that
the user will enter their credit card
details in
then i'm also going to show you a
confirmation of an actual charge from
stripe and we'll set a loading state to
false
we can define the handler during ng on
init and we do that by calling stripe
checkout configure
and at this point you'll need to pass it
your stripe publishable key
you can find that by going to the stripe
dashboard under developers api
keys there's a bunch of different
options that you can pass in here to
customize things like the avatar image
and things like that
but the important thing is that you
define a callback for either the source
or the token
when the user enters their payment
details they will be securely
transferred to stripe
and then striper will spawn back to your
front end with a tokenized version of
the payment source or credit card
so the code right here will run after
the user has entered their card details
stripe has validated that card and now
we can use it to actually create a
charge on our own server
there's quite a few things that you'll
want to do here first we'll set the
loading state to true
and then we'll get the currently
authenticated user the backend that we
build on the stripe master course is
based on firebase callable functions
this is a special type of http function
that gives us the context of the
currently authenticated user
this means we can make requests to our
backend without having to set
authorization headers manually
in this case we just need to pass a
source and an amount and our backend
will charge the card that will take a
second or two and then we'll go ahead
and set the loading state to false
and that's all it takes to create a
charge from our back end the only thing
left to do is create a method here
called checkout that will open the
handler when the user clicks a button
you can also add additional details here
for example you might want to add the
user's email address
and the amount and description of the
product we can also close the handler
manually
and we'll want to do that if the user
clicks the back button by adding a host
listener to the window pop state event
in the html we'll just go ahead and
create a button and then we'll bind the
click event to that checkout handler
now when creating the amount for a
stripe charge it will always be in the
currency's smallest denomination which
for us dollars would be pennies
and that's why i divide the amount by
100 so we have the actual dollar amount
to show in the ui
and then i'll add ngf here for the
loading state and also for the
confirmation that we get back from our
back end
now when a customer goes online to buy
some meat from our store they have a
modal to enter their credit card details
that is not only secure but also looks
pretty nice
after the card is captured it will run
the code in that callback
it first puts the app in the loading
state for a few seconds then it responds
with a charge object from stripe
which has all kinds of information about
the charge itself like the id the amount
and stuff like that
so overall that was very easy and we
created a real charge in the striped
testing environment
but the main drawback to stripe checkout
is that we don't have a lot of control
over the checkout experience
we can change the logo and some of the
options but everything else is basically
hard-coded into that modal
luckily stripe has another library
called stripe elements that allows you
to build checkout forms without having
to do everything from scratch
we use stripe elements on fireship and
as you can see here we get the same
validation and security that we get with
the checkout form
however it is a lot easier to customize
and as you can see here it easily adapts
to multiple themes
and it's really not that much more
difficult to set up so first we're going
to go into the index.html
and this time import stripe.js version
3.
we'll declare a global variable for
stripe and this time the typings are
under the stripe namespace
now the component will start off just
like the previous one did we pass in the
amount and the product description
but then we need to grab a dom element
to attach the payment form to
so viewchild will be looking for a
template reference called card element
which we'll create once we get to the
html
now we have a few things to declare here
we have the instance of stripe elements
itself
we have the card that represents the
actual card details and then any card
errors
and then we'll also have a loading state
and a confirmation from our back end
now you can initialize stripe with your
publishable key and then stripe elements
will give you access to a bunch of
different form fields
if you just have a generic credit card
form you can create the card element and
that's all you need that will give you a
nice single line for the card itself but
you can break that down into multiple
fields if you want from here we'll go
ahead and mount the card to the actual
dom element which we do by calling card
element native element in angular
at this point we need to attach an event
listener to changes to the card form
in this example we're just going to
display the card errors but you might
also want to disable the submit button
if the card is not valid
when it comes to stripe elements we need
to handle the actual submission of the
payment form
unlike the previous example where we
defined a source callback this time
we'll actually call stripe create source
and then handle it inside this async
function if there are any errors then
we'll go ahead and show those in the
view
otherwise we're going to run the same
exact logic that we ran in that source
handler which involves getting the
current user
calling the callable function to create
the charge in the back end and then
setting the loading state to false
now we can switch over to the html and
first we'll create a form element
and then we'll bind the handle form
method to the submission of this form
then we'll create a div with hashtag
card element that creates the template
variable that we can actually mount to
and then we'll also display the card
errors here as well and that's all it
takes to build a validated and secure
payment form with stripe and angular
now we can just drop this component
anywhere in our angular app and we have
a quick and easy way for users to pay
for products or sign up for
subscriptions
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you're serious
about building a payment system with
stripe consider becoming a pro member at
fireship io i'm leaving a discount code
down in the description
and if you have any questions make sure
to leave me a comment thanks for
watching and i will talk to you soon
oh